what up space fam golson here from anime
upbringing and i'm back at it again to
not only discuss the latest crazy attack
on time episode but the last one we'll
get in a while and we'll talk about the
future of the anime as well
and what's actually happening with the
so-called final season so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these attack on time videos on
the channel and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do is
warhammer
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next video to
come out feel free to check out my
growing attack on time playlist which
includes videos about all time shifters
all acronyms and much more
link to that is in the description
before we get into it a big thank you to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video one
of the things that annoys me the most
is paying full price for a streaming
service but then not having access to
a lot of the content on that service
just because i live in the wrong country
since i am in canada i often find that
the streaming services i pay for
don't have the same content as they do
in other countries
if you pay full price for streaming
service you deserve access to all of its
content and that's where expressvpn
comes in
expressvpn allows you to access
literally thousands of shows and movies
from all over the world by changing your
ip address
and that also makes it more difficult
for third parties to track you
or mine your data so for example the
anime samurai shamplo is not available
on netflix canada but
is available on netflix uk with
expressvpn i can gain access to samurai
shamplo
on netflix in just a few seconds just
download the app on your phone
or computer tap one button and you're
good to go protect yourself today and
gain access to the content you paid for
with expressvpn
go to expressvpn.com anime uproar to get
three extra months for free
this is a limited time offer so visit
expressvpn.com
anime uproar right now now without
further ado let's jump into it so this
episode is called above and below and
that title will make more sense near the
end of the episode and we'll get to that
we start out where we left off after
zeke's explosion
as i said in the last review it totally
looked like this explosion could have
finished off zeke and levi
we don't see levi here so anime onlys
can place their bets about what happened
to him in the comments
but zeke we do see and he's actually
clinging a bit to life
even as most of his body has been blown
off it's pretty crazy
he does see an image of a girl which
anime onlys can speculate about but the
significant thing
is a titan does take zeke inside its
body
weird yes but definitely significant
notably it didn't eat him
but rather seems to have helped him out
perhaps he can heal
easier in there where perhaps some of
the titan flesh can help his own body
recover
either way because of this you can't
count zeke out yet
even though almost anyone else would
have been dead after that explosion
again as i mentioned before attaching a
thunder spirit to zeke was not levi's
best idea we then jumped to pixas
and yelena sitting at the same table but
this time the roles are reversed
yelena is definitely too crazy about
zeke there's no doubt about that but
she's
also a really interesting character to
watch and here the tables have turned
and yelena is the one in the position of
power rather than pixes
and she's not treating him that bad like
flock treated shotis
so she gets points for that too pixis
didn't trust zeke and wanted to kill him
and zeke in turn
made sure the high ranking officials
consumed his titan serum so he could
change them with the scream if need be
or use them as living hostages clearly
no one here is a saint
and they were clearly both right not to
trust each other and the spinal fluid
plan worked out really well because now
pix has pretty much told his men not to
go against the jaegerists because they
can potentially be turned at any moment
not only that his own comrades started
putting guns at him too
so he really didn't have much of a
choice and it's interesting hearing the
reasons why people turned against him in
one case
a man and his son consumed the spinal
fluid so he's doing all that to save
their lives
you can't really blame him just like the
merlions do with families
the jaegers have pretty much taken his
son's life hostage
another marlene parallel is the armbands
now people are wearing different colored
bands
to help identify them white are early
jagerists who get the advantages of
switching sides sooner they're red are
those who drank the blood and
are now working for them and it seems
like the black bands
are for people who drink the wine and
don't know what's going on
and their side is probably unclear it
seems obvious that the methods the
jaegerists are using are definitely
similar to the marlian methods but do
you think the same methods can be more
or less justified
depending on what the end goal is is
freeing the world
of the titan curse more admirable than
doing these things to try to maintain
marlene supremacy let me know what you
think in the comments i absolutely love
tackling the philosophical questions
that attack on titan poses
for yelena it's all justified because
they're saving the world
she knows the true plan rather than the
one pixas had in mind which was to use
the rumbling to keep the world at bay
for 50 years while technology
expands quickly enough for them to be
able to defend themselves without
relying on titans we then jump to
another prison cell
and this time connie jean armin and
mikasa are the ones in jail rather than
aaron p.s nicolo is there too connie is
known as being pretty dense and he's
also known for being one of the first to
assume the worst about aaron
here he again says that they know aaron
is a total piece of crap so it's not
surprising to him that he would hurt the
two people who care the most about him
but
jon i think is on to something when he
says and i quote if aaron was sane
he wouldn't do it without good reason
and quote and this
is the intelligent thing to conclude
especially given everything we know
about aaron and his previous behavior
even if he did hate mikasa and armin it
wouldn't serve his purposes to meet them
just to tell them that
rather it seems more like the time
nicolo dissed
jean for being ldn in order to save him
from
zeke's spinal fluid in my view it
wouldn't make sense if aaron's speech to
armin and mikasa were his true and
honest thoughts
and i'm glad jon seems to have caught on
to that as well
another part which was interesting and
kind of hilarious to me
was the guy who kept calling out nicolo
for having the hots for devil spawn who
reeked of potatoes let me know if i'm
the only one who thought it was funny
when yelena just blew his brains out
she pretty much did what everyone else
wanted to do there and then said
there is no need for those who call you
devils on this island
yeah yelana is merciless sometimes but
i like that you can see she does have a
strong sense of justice and isn't cruel
just for the sake of being cruel
at this point she tells them about the
euthanization plan that zeke has
assuring them that she doesn't want
something hollow like revenge
but to end the cycle of hatred to save
ld and even marley
and although i can get behind ending the
cycle of hatred
i just can't get behind their means to
doing it i think solving the problem by
wiping out the alden race peacefully or
not is ridiculous
however armin doesn't seem to think so
and seems touched by the plan finally
having learned the truth
it's definitely not what he expected i
look forward to learning more about
armin's true thoughts about this plan
then we have the aaron and gabby scene
which is quickly interrupted by
peak showing up and shooting the guard
at this point in the anime you gotta
expect for people to just get shot out
of nowhere
again i really like how in attack on
titan all this important stuff seems to
happen
in the background of the scene like when
aaron walked into the room while armin
and mikasa were talking
or here where pique just strolls in it
works really well and i'm glad we don't
get to see multiple close-ups of peak
approaching the
room before she comes into it the
element of surprise is great and i like
the way these important moments tend to
be
understated rather than overemphasized
long story short peak fakes
being on aaron's side to get him to the
roof what is good about pique is that
she comes up with a convincing argument
for why she would be on aaron's side
because he can help
free all aldeans in marley and around
the world including her father
as she points out to gabby after ldns
are no longer necessary to marley
because advanced military technology has
made titan powers obsolete
then marlians will erase them from
existence so they may as well strike
back against marley before that happens
and we'll get back to peak but i gotta
say though you not only notice how tall
aaron is here compared to peak you also
notice how much of a badass he is
like for instance when peak is
threatening to shoot him he just walks
into the gun
and tells her to shoot knowing that
marley would want him alive
so they can take the power of the
founder this aaron is definitely not
nice but i really appreciate how badass
he is
he has to be one of the coolest shonen
protagonists hands down but yeah when
she's trying to trick aaron pique is so
convincing you really aren't that
convinced when she turns out to be on
marley's side after all
why keep fighting for marley when they
take ldn families hostage and treat them
as
devils the only saving grace here is
that when talking to gabby after the
reveal
she says that she doesn't trust marley
but she does trust the comrades she
fought alongside of
i don't agree with the euthanization
plan but i also don't agree with the
helping marley plan either and much more
related to when pique said they needed
to secure their right to live
with their own hands when she was trying
to convince aaron she was on his side
like that actually makes a lot of sense
when compared to trusted merlin's plan
despite the fact that i'm not too
convinced by peak's rationale
i did think that the part where she was
supposed to point out the enemies and
she pointed to aaron was pretty epic
porco's draw tight attacks from below
and we see multiple airships from above
which is what the title of the episode
must have been referring to
below and above aaron is under attack
the war has been brought to them on
parody again
and before aaron could make contact with
zeke aaron avoids
getting eaten by porco and transforms
leaving the final battle in attack on
titan to begin
the one that will decide at all who will
win and what will aaron do
if he does win it's truly a crazy moment
and things are going to be action-packed
from here on
out the stage is set for marley to try
and get revenge for what happened
against liberio
reiner is seen in an airship too all the
warriors have made it here for this
final stand against aaron the man who
has turned himself
into the enemy of the world and even
tried to turn armin and mikasa against
him too
can't wait to see aaron's new combined
titan powers using the warhammer
and attack and eventually perhaps the
phallic titan power after he meets up
with zeke
we've entered the craziest part of
attack on titan and yet
now we gotta wait which is kind of weird
so let's get into
when the next episode is coming out this
was called attack on titan final season
and we were expecting 16 episodes and we
got him but we also knew
this wouldn't be enough episodes to
finish off the story so some were saying
there would be a movie to finish it off
or they'd rush the ending or leave it
undone so you have to read the manga but
luckily it turns out we will get more
episodes
the only thing is it looks like we'll be
waiting until winter 2022
for part 2 of the final season to drop
which may well include another 16
episodes the confusing part to me
is if both parts include 16 or so
episodes and will be
a whole year apart it probably would
have made more sense
and caused less confusion to call them
different seasons
that would have been easier to
understand in my view but hey not a big
deal i'm just very excited that they
won't rush the ending even if i will
have to be more patient than i thought i
would have to be
to get the rest of the final season and
that is it my friends
the last episode review for a while it
seems like make sure you are subscribed
though and have that notification bell
on because the final chapter of the
manga will come out any day now
so you won't want to miss that the
official ending of attack on titan is so
insanely close
if you did enjoy this video and want to
keep the attack on time videos coming
the best thing you can do is warhammer
smash that like button until it's blue
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
attack on titan playlist which includes
videos about all titan shifters the
ackermans and much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you